i know that's the biggest mystery to me
and my sisters
kim kardashian opens up about ending
keeping up with the kardashians
after 20 seasons it was a whirlwind
and the one thing that really blows her
mind
we are blown away during a recent chat
with good morning vogue
the 40 year old reality star said that
she and her sisters
can't get over how much their voices
have changed since season one
whose voice do i hear the princess is in
the building
you're obviously in a really interesting
mood
that's the biggest mystery to me and my
sisters we
are blown away it's the thing that has
us absolutely blown away
we have no idea what happened to our
voices we have completely different
voices
your voice deepens yes all of ours do
kim also got candid about her famous
family's decision to walk away from
their hit show
and we just kept on going back and forth
on that and then we all were like listen
we're all going to have to
we're all sentimental we all
really love doing this and we love our
cat our crew
so much that i think that was such a
huge decision for us
because we loved seeing them and working
with them and we've been in our lives
from
season one so it it was an emotional
decision but we all felt like it was the
right decision
the kkw beauty founder said that the
most emotional moment for her
came when they broke the news to the
crew that season 20 would be their last
i think i was also super emotional when
my um
audio girl gave me my mic she gave me my
my mic that i've had and they tracked
down with the serial numbers that it was
my mic
through the first 10 seasons and then we
switched to a different mic that they
look identical i think for the last 10
seasons
back in september shortly after the
family announced that their show would
be coming to
an end ryan seacrest who is an executive
producer on keeping up
told et that the family's choice to walk
away was not an easy one
in talking to the family this was a very
very hard decision for them to make
and and i know even you know before and
after the announcement came out
they were emotional we were trading
texts and emails after the announcement
uh and you look back at 14 years and 20
seasons of a camera
in your life and think about that at
some point you're gonna say
you know we did it we had a great run
we're gonna live with a little more
privacy in our lives and i think they
just felt like
now is the time to do it and kim she
said she's feeling grateful these days
following a difficult year which
included the end of her six-year
marriage to kanye west
i think that this year has been
so challenging for so many people but i
also think that this year
was a huge cleanse and just a huge
opportunity for people to really
be grateful for the simple things and
that
is a huge i think awakening that so many
people had
and she's looking on the bright side
even though it's been such a challenging
year
i think it's been a time to regenerate
get creative
spend so much time with family and just
this time that i've been able to spend
with my children has been
you know priceless